belle marianne vous dormirez
tranquillement le coeur de celio et à
une autre est ce n'est plus sous vos
fenêtres qu'il jouera sa sérénade
quel dommage et quel grand malheur de
n'avoir pu partager un amour comme celui
là vous voyez comme le hasard me
contrarie mois qu'elle est en vérité oui
sur mon âme ce soir ou demain matin
dimanche au plus tard je viens à
parthenay qui pouvait ne pas réussir
avec un ambassadeur tels que vous il
faut croire que sa passion pour moi
était quelque chose comme du chinois ou
de l'arabe puisqu'il lui fallait un
interprète et qu'elle ne pouvait
s'expliquer tout seul rail rail et nous
ne vous croyons plus ou peut-être que
cet amour n'était encore qu'un pauvre
enfant à la mamelle et vous comme une
sage nourrissent en le maintenant à la
lumière
vous n'aurez laissé tombé la tête la
première en le promenant dans la vie la
sage nourrissent s'est contenté de lui
faire boire à certains allaient que la
vôtre vous a versé sans douté et
généreusement vous en avez encore sur
les lèvres
une goutte qui se mène à toutes vos
paroles comment s'appelle ce merveilleux
l'indifférence vous ne pouvez nier mais
niait y est vous êtes comme les roses du
bengale marianne sans épines et sans
parfum il dit lundi
aviez vous préparé devant cette
comparaison
si vous ne voulez pas le brouillon de
voir randonnée le mois de grâce fut g20
prenne à ma perruche qui trouvez vous
qu'il puisse vous blesser une fleur sans
parfum n'en est pas moins belle
mais au contraire ce sont les plus
belles que tu as fait ainsi et il joue
ou comme une galette est d'une nouvelle
espèce vous deviendrez de marbre au fond
de quelques églises
ce sera une charmante de statut que vous
ferez et qui ne laissera pas que de
trouver quelques niches respectable dans
un confessionnal
mon cher cousin est ce que vous ne
craignez pas le sort des femmes voyez un
peu ce qui m'arrive il est décrété par
le sort que ces lieux mêmes où quelque 3
mai mais lequel celio le dit à ses amis
lesquels j'ai mis des crêtes à leur tour
que sous peine de mort je serai sa
maîtresse la jeunesse d'un polythène
dagne m'envoyer en votre personne
un digne représentant chargé de me faire
savoir que j'ai à aimer le dit seigneur
celio d'ici à une huitaine de jours
faisais cela je vous en prie si je me
rends que dira-t-on mois
n'est ce pas une femme bien abject que
celle qui obéit à point nommé à l'heure
convenue à une pareille proposition ne
va-t-on pas la déchirer à belles dents
l'a montré du doigt et faire de son nom
le refrain d'une chanson à boire
s'il refuse au contraire qu'elle a
monstre qui lui soient comparables est
il une statue plus froides quel est
l'homme qui lui parle qui osent
l'arrêter en place publique son livre
demain salama n'at-il pas le droit de
lui dire vous êtes une rose du bengale
sans épines et sans parfum cous une
cousine ne vous fâchez pas l'espèce une
chose bien ridicule que l'honnêteté et
la fois gérer que l'éducation d'une
fille que la fierté dunkerque et ses
figures et qu'il manque quelque chose
eq avant de jeter au vent la poussière
de sa fleur chéri il faut que de khalis
en soi baignés de larmes
épanouie par quelques rayons
mais entre ouvert par quelques mains
délicates
tout cela n'est-il pas un rêve une bulle
de savon que le premier soupir d'un
cavalier à la mode doivent évaporés dans
les airs vous méprenez sur mon compte
sur youtube car après tout qu'une femme
l'occupation d'un moment une coupe
fragile qui renferme une goutte de rosée
qu'on porte à ses lèvres et qu'on jette
par dessus son épaule
une femme c'est une partie de plaisir
ne pourrait-on pas dire quand on en
rencontre une voilà une belle nuit qui
passe ne serait-ce pas un grand écho
lire de telles matières que celui qui
baisserait les yeux devant elle il se
dirait tout bas on l'a peut-être le
bonheur d'une vie entière et qu'il la
laisserait passer
il
coups au delà quelle drôle de kits
femmes